hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
Clym Eric antigen receptors from
proof-of-concept to widely applicable
clinical research solutions presented by
dr. Deena Schneider we're excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Milton a biotech Milton a biotech is a
global provider of products and services
that advanced biomedical research and
cellular therapy the company's
innovative tools support research at
every level from basic research to
translational research to clinical
applications this integrated portfolio
enables scientists and clinicians to
obtain analyze and utilize the cell
Milton T biotechs technologies covered
techniques of sample preparation cell
isolation cell sorting flow cytometry
cell culture molecular analysis and
preclinical imaging there more than 25
years of expertise span research areas
including immunology stem cell biology
neuroscience and cancer and clinical
research areas like hematology graft
engineering and apheresis
the company also offers comprehensive
scientific support consultation and
expert training to learn more about
Milka new biotech visit WWLP biotech com
I am Judy Oracle a Bert's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CC button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you can use
the Q&A button to let us know your have
problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. Schneider dr. Schneider
holds a PhD in pharmacology and
toxicology from Michigan State
University for doctoral thesis focused
on pathways of B cell activation and
differentiation her postdoctoral work
focused on cellular immune responses to
viral infections in airway inflammatory
diseases in 2011 dr. Schneider
transitioned to industry where she
contributed to numerous projects in
synthetic immunology immunotherapy and
chimeric antigen receptor car T cell
based therapy dr. Schneider leads the
cell biology group at linkage in
technology a Milton E biotech company
her group focuses on preclinical
development of novel car based therapies
and on the implementation of the clinics
prodigy platform for preparation of cell
based therapeutics please join me in
welcoming dr. Schneider I will now turn
the presentation over to her thank you
Judy and hello everyone so today we'll
be speaking about car t-cells and I
would like to begin by giving you the
overview of my today's presentation so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
what car t-cells are and I will show you
how car t-cells are both an emerging
technology and now if you approve gene
therapy products and then we'll speak
about viral vectors that are used or can
be used to engineer t-cells for adaptive
cell therapy and then I will show you an
example of a development of a car
construct and its journey from RG all
the way to the clinic and we'll speak
about manufacturing of GMP great car
t-cell products for clinical trials
where I will show give you an overview
of kartik clinical trials as currently
practiced and then we will conclude by
saying a few words about current K cells
so with that we will proceed so what are
car T cells called T stands for chimeric
antigen receptor
in cells and these cells are generated
through synthetic biology so as you all
probably know an antibody depicted in
the slide here in Figure a and B is
comprised of two having and few light
chains and each antibody has a region
which is responsible for recognition of
an antigen and antibody binding and that
region is comprised of the variable
heavy and variable light fragments
through synthetic biology these
fragments can be linked together to
create what is called FC FV single chain
fragment variable and those SC of three
fragments are commonly used in the
generation of Karthik our T cell
receptors so in the figure on the right
is an example of use of SCO fee-based
binding domain in-car structure on the
left of the figure you can see depicted
a tumor cell at the top and a T cell at
the bottom receptor on the left is a car
T receptor and it's comprised of a
binder which is a variable having my
chain that is linked by a hinge entrance
membrane domain to intracellular
signaling domains of the receptor while
the binder is responsible for
recognition of a specific targeted
epitope on to most tumor cell surface
the signaling domains are responsible
for initiating an intracellular
signaling cascade which eventually
causes T cell to become activated and
kill the tumor cell on the right you can
see a traditional T cell receptor TCR
and you can and as you can see there is
a lot of differences between a car and a
TCR I will point out just a few that
will be important to distinguish car in
our talk
one difference is in TCR signaling the
antigen has to be processed by tumor
cell and presented in peptide MHC
context to TCR which is then activated
and is activating the t-cell in our case
of the presentation of the antigen is
MHC independent therefore it can target
much broadly antigens present on tumors
because it does not require recognition
in the context of a specific image see
so where did colors T cells come from
this technology first emerged in 1989
and in a group that vitamin Institute in
Israel directed but by the doctors Alec
HR and first publications were
interesting but have not generated a lot
of interest in the field and it actually
took a lot of years until this
technology progressed from its first
applications into actual clinical
applications as you can see in the slide
here from the first application circa
1989 to 2010 when first clinical trials
were done using car constructs we took a
long time and this evolution included
exchanging car targeting domains
exchanging car signaling domains
it's an introducing kosta military
domain here in the figure the Christian
military domain depicted on the right
for 2010 to cd28 and it took all these
years to come from a general idea into
actual applicable product that can be
used in the clinic so cars are often
referred to by their generation what
does that designation stand for
as you can see in this figure each each
receptor so on the Left depicted at the
bottom left is a t-cell receptor complex
and this complex contains the cd3 zeta
molecule there's there are two series a
test which are the actual component of
the t-cell receptor complex that
initiates the intracellular signaling
and causes T cell to become activated in
first-generation cars the CDC zeta
intracellular domain was used your
transmembrane domain that was commonly
from cd28 or cd8 molecule which in turn
was used to anti-tumor targeting domains
the single chain as we derived derived
amine as I alluded to earlier so in the
first generation card the only signaling
domain present is the cd3 zeta later on
it became understood that it's helpful
for car T cells to have a second domain
that helps with the signaling and cd28
was the first co stimulatory domain that
was introduced so if the car has a
costimulatory domain such as cd28
for when we be me or ox40 in addition
facility related signaling domain that
is a second-generation car and even
later on in additional development there
constructs were made that contain two
signaling domains for example 400 B and
C be 28 together and that is a
third-generation car so this is a nun in
creature now as you can imagine now that
this technology has been realized we are
in an era where we can view car
construction as as a car shop basically
the idea is that it's modular you can
select whichever you want car targeting
domains whichever you want linkers
whichever you want signal signaling
domains co-stimulatory domains in
combine them together
you construct a car with the properties
that you want so you could select from
one model one type of custom that can be
made is active car which is comprised of
targeting the main transmembrane domain
co-stimulatory the main activation
domain or you can have constructs that
have just discrete data without the
co-stimulatory domain core trans used
together with would confirm that only
half core stimulatory domain in that
case you would split your signal in
between two different molecules and we
would require engagement of both
molecules in order to generate maximal T
cell activation and as we will show you
later it might very important in some
more sophisticated car designs you could
have tandem cars where you have tu
targeting domains connected to each
other and so the car would be activating
by binding either one of the two
epitopes that are targeted you can have
inducible cars or you can have cars that
require a small molecule ligand for for
the car extracellular and intracellular
portions to come together and initiate
signaling in all these innovations allow
better control of car function so one of
the issues that stands in front of cars
field is car safety even though car has
shown very promising results in the
clinic safety remains a major concern
and so over the years there have been
many approaches that have been tried in
order to make car safer or to better
control the lengths of time throughout
which the car is active and so safety
mechanism that having tried our safety
by suicide
meaning car T cells can suicide when
they're told to or one a treatment is
applied tagging car T cells or transient
expression of car T cells
so in the figure that I'm showing now
you have in a B and C three different
methods for controlling car T cell
person presence HS 50k is a tiny beam
kinase while time is in kinase derived
molecule that is introduced into the t
cell together with the car and when a
drug called ganciclovir is given to the
patient activation of this molecule
makes diesel die by apoptosis so that's
one way that you could eliminate car T
cells if they are causing toxicity in
the patient another similar mechanism is
depicted in panel B and that's inducible
caspase-9 and here in addition of a
soluble molecule which is a dimer Iser
allows the immunization of synthetic i
test base nine domains within the car t
cell which leads again to t cell
apoptosis the mechanism depicted in C is
the truncated EGFR receptor it's a surf
cell surface receptor which is truncated
so that it does not have any signaling
capacity but it can be recognized by
antibodies attack Sima which is a
clinical grade antibody and then the T
cell can be targeted by elimination to
eliminate elimination by ADC or a DCC
mechanism again it's a way of getting
rid of unwanted details and finally
generating car T cells by RNAi
electroporation results in transient
expression of the car and so the cells
are only functional for the duration of
scar expression the downside of this
method though is that it would require
multiple applications of car T cells for
prolonged activity so it does it might
benefit in terms of safety but the
efficacy might be affected another way
to control car function is by
chakal gates so in the panel depicted
here
you either have an invisible car or a
logic gated car or on switch color or a
masked car so each one of these
mechanism again allows you to activate
the car in a more controlled fashion
with the inducible car you would only
activate the car if signal a but not
signal means present and in this model
this only happens from two mortician
that way car is not going to be active
against normal tissue that might be
expressing the same antigen that tumor
is targeting in logical gated car cells
activation of a and B is actually both
is required for full activation of the
car in the on switch car there is an
inducible ident again which is required
for inter cellar the main activation of
the car and mask are actually contains a
domain that is masking the fgfe binding
domain and when the car is present in
tumor microenvironment the protease is
in the environment relief the mask and
allow the binding domain to bind so
these are all different methods which
have been proposed for controlling car
function another approach you want to
talk about is the universal car and this
car is basically would be a product that
would be generated from a universal
donor and would that would be then being
being able to be given to any patient
and in order for that to happen two
modifications have to be done on such a
car one is the division of the
endogenous TCR to prevent graft versus
whole series and another is the deletion
of major histocompatibility complex
genes to prevent in unit
objection of the car by the host so this
approach is also being worked on is
still in relatively early stages that
it's a very promising technology and
another technology I would like to
mention is CRISPR cast nine it's a is
impacting and will continue to impact
cell engineering and basically as I told
you presently what we are doing we are
introducing the car molecule into a
t-cell that does contain its own TCR and
does contain its own inhibitory
receptors and so it could be the because
of that the car function is not optimal
however CRISPR technology allows you
specifically target DNA insertions into
the particular locus and in that case if
for example we wanted to eliminate the
endogenous TCR it's possible to target
car expression into the TCR locus in
that way in one step you would both
remove the TCR and allow better car
expression so that is a very promising
technology that is being worked on right
now also I want to mention to you that
in order to select the best cars for the
job
another approach is possible it's not
only molecular engineering of the cell
it's also the selection of the relevant
t-cell subsets and the shown here is a
publication by dr. Betty mony group
showing that vice using central stem
cell memory P cells for car applications
it's possible to increase their
functionality basically shown here are
on the left in vivo model mice that did
not get any treatment and that's high
level tumor board and by day 12 and then
in the middle standard application of
car cell so the
are not selected for any particular
phenotype and on the right application
of stealth stem cell memory enriched
party cells and you can see it results
in more efficacious human elimination so
to summarize this part there is a number
of different emerging car technologies
in to produce cars that are better
controlled more functional and safer and
the factors that matter are the
selection of the initial self substrate
such as stem cell memory or central
memory cells or cd4 cd8 positive T cells
or virus specific T cells
the other consideration is the gene
vector is just a car
ordering additional factors added such
as solo factors that increase car
functionality next generation gated cars
all the new innovations I talked to you
about to better control the time of car
T cell functionality and the finally
target selection so the targets that
cortisol targets are sometimes are not
unique for tumors they are highly
expressed in tumors or they are specific
to a linear such as envy so leukemias
and lymphomas and so loss of lineage is
tolerable even though it's not ideal but
one Avenue that needs to be explored
more in the future is finding targets
that are very selective for the tumor
and not present on normal tissue that
will also increase car safety so now I
would like to switch gears and talk
about viral vectors for adoptive cell
therapy so retroviral vectors such as
gamma rays oil retro viral vectors and
Lenti viral vectors are infectious and
pathogenic I'm sorry the viruses are
infections and pathogenic the viral
vectors are modest ways on the virus but
are modified in a way
that they are application deficient and
can be used as a therapeutic so depicted
here is a viral life cycle so when a
very on infects a cell it fuses with
cell membrane and releases its genomic
RNA which is then transcribed to cDNA
and integrated in the host genome of the
provirus and then transcribed and
translated and assembled into variants
which bud from the cell surface that's
what that's the virus life cycle now in
in the use of lentiviral vector several
elements of the viral genome have been
modified in a way that the vector is
efficient in getting into the cell and
delivering the DNA into host genome but
is incapable of replication and
infection so how is that achieved the
length of viral genome depicted here
between two ltrs is comprised of a
number of structural proteins and
basically the gags the pole and the end
and the revs are the important proteins
in the viral genome so in order to
generate viral vectors that are not able
to propagate infection but are good for
delivering DNA materials a system has
been generated called self inactivated
vector and in this system a number of
steps have been taken to make it safe so
the first step was that the the
packaging vector I'm sorry the transfer
vector only contains the transgene
material under under a recombinant
promoter in this case TGK promoter but
not any of the structural genes that are
required for viral
cycle and replication that's the first
precaution another precaution is that a
portion of the ltr' has been deleted so
that the virus is unable to replicate on
its own once it's in a provider stage in
addition the other components that are
required to generate viral particles gas
pole and wealth have been split into
multiple plasmids so in the four plasmid
system case there are four different
plasmids
one is the plugin containing their car
sequence of interest and the separate
president were encoding the gag and Pol
and yet a separate cost plasma encoding
the Rev sequence and a separate present
including the envelope sequence and that
way those plasmids there's a very small
chance that they would ever come
together and recombine to form a
function functional virus again and in
fact it such case has never been seen in
the clinic in all the history of
application of Lenti viral vectors so
car therapy requires production of lunch
viral vectors at commercial scale how
can that be achieved so in this diagram
here is shown a schematic of the viral
production process so here we are
starting with for plasmid system and
those planets are transfected into HEC
energy cells which are the production
lines and then while viral particles are
produced and secreted into culture
supernatant from there they are isolated
and purified and the used for
transduction of target cells and then
cargill cells target cells acquired the
gene of interest and express it
so a plant again we have we have a fully
developed GMP material vector
manufacturing process for
generate viral vectors for adoptive cell
therapy
it starts from upstream culture to
tangential flow filtration to
chromatography to sterile filtration to
Box Hill and it produces highly pure
land survival vector with robust
functional tighter now I would like to
switch gears and tell you about a
journey of one car from R&D to the
clinic so we are going to talk about an
or logical gate car that is targeting
cd20 and cv 19 antigens on tumor surface
simultaneously and it's intended for the
treatment of cd19 positive and/or cd20
positive hematologic malignancies and
the idea behind this approach is that by
targeting few antigens and tumor surface
simultaneously we will be able to
mitigate tumor antigen escapes so
depicted here are two different car
constructs one that starts with a CD 19
FC FV link to CD 20s C of V and in turn
link to CD a transmembrane and hinge
domain and CD 123 which is the same as
for one VD domain which is a cocoa
octave ation domain and seriously is it
a signaling domain that's the structure
of the car that's one configuration the
other configuration is CD twenty binding
domain first link to cd19 domain and
then followed by cd8 leaving 137
symmetry great as before and also in
addition to those tandem car versions we
have generated a single targeting
control targeting either cd19 or 320 and
depicted in the bottom panel is a
phosphate American metric analysis of
car expression on cell surface and in
order to achieve this assessment we use
three different methods one method is a
staining of car with protein elk
protein L binds to a CFC white chain of
the Kappa Kappa type and so it would
recognize non-discriminatory the cd19
and cd20 binding domains and then on the
right are depicted two specific
detection methods that detect either
cd19 binder or cd20 binder on the
surface of the car express himself only
and as you can see in both cases
expression of the binders expression of
the cars was pretty high one thing to
point out is for 1920 consideration when
we looked at cd20 PE so expression of
cd20 binder we picked up much less
signal than than we did for the 2019
construct and that is a hint that in
this configuration the 20 binding is
probably not optimal so that will be
important for future slides so then we
use the in vitro system for killing
assay to expose yourself the potency of
these cars and we use multiple cell
lines that either expressed both cd19
and CB 20 such as Rajee and normal and
as you can see of when both antigens
were expressed
we got specific killings using the cars
expressing the common contagion
Chanin 3 t-cells are a 15 18 to 20
negative line so there is no killing in
this line the RH clone we have is a CD
20 negative and as you can see again the
cars that expressed either cd19 only or
or CD 19 and 20 were able to kill this
line but not car expression C 20 only
again it's an indication of specificity
and in the top row shown are k562 cells
which are again cd19 tonal negatives so
there is no specific killing or gave a
secure cells that specifically Express
cv 19 or
20 and again the killing was
antigen-specific so we see that our cars
are specific to the antigen they're
targeting the next figure I'm showing is
the cytokine release acid for car sells
Co Co intubated with Rajee tumor lined
and as you can see here where as the
single cars targeting civilian team both
and used cytokines interferon gamma il-2
T and F alpha and GM CSF the cd20 single
targeting car used the much greater
levels of cytokines and by contrast the
tandem cars produce cytokines an
intermediate level which might be
optimal for clinical applications and
then we proceeded to test our cars and
in in vivo model and Raja mice in Raja
tumor model in NSG mice and as you can
see here our tandem cars were able to
eliminate to more efficiently so then we
wanted to look at the mechanism also
tumor antigen escaped and how our cars
behaved in that regard and it the reason
we are concerned with this issue is that
in the clinic and cd19 trials a large
fairly large amount of patients had
relapsed with cv 19 negative tumors and
so it's important to understand this
phenomenon and to find ways to mitigate
that so what we found when we call
incubated our cars with rajat cells or
with MAO themselves
we found that cars targeting cd19 alone
downregulated seeking the 19 surface
expression on the tumors similarly to
what has been seen in the clinic
however the tandem cars preserved much
greater levels of cd19 expression and
also allowed the city 20 levels to be
preserved at greater well also
that makes the tandem car a more
favorable construct to target both
antigens without little risk of losing
them and then finally to better
differentiate between our cars which
performs another integral experiment in
which my cell were bearing tumors with
very high burden so we allowed the key
works to grow in the mind so much longer
period of time and we tested either the
2019 tandem car or a mixture of cd19 car
cells and cd4 20-car cells noted here as
1984 28 or 19 B plus 28 or a single
application of either cd20 car or cd19
car and what we found out is that the
best profile in terms of tumor clearance
and my survival was obtained for the
2019 ton tandem car as you can see here
are all six I survived and the tumor has
been greatly controlled greatly reduced
for 1919 B 5 out of 6 I survived and the
humor was still present for all the
groups that contain cd20 car either by
itself or in combination with a CB 19
car q white image group where tumor
well the tumor control was very good for
too much in each group however the rest
of the mice were found bad and that is
probably due to high toxicity of the
treatment which might be an excited kind
really syndromes in people so what we
found out is that the 2019 car is both
effective in tumor elimination and has a
more favorable toxicity profile in this
NSG mouse model so we work with a very
talented group of investigators at the
Medical College of Wisconsin led by dr.
ha and we are happy to report the amount
of clinical trial has been open for the
2019 cars in patients with relapsed
refractory visual malignancy and we are
very excited about that
and now I would like to speak about the
manufacturer of car t-cells so as you
probably can imagine there are multiple
challenges for x miu SLE processing of
cell and gene therapy products and
queuing manufacturing protocols can be
characterized by complex processes which
have lost and their standardization and
loaded for disability and high levels of
manual operations there are many open
processing steps and there is a high
risk of quality events and overall cost
of goods is relatively high because of
all of these factors so another way to
generate car t-cells is to have an
integrated process so the steps required
in Carta generation is logical phoresis
self selection cell activation cell
transduction cell expansion some cell
product formulation and finally
administration to the patient and as I
have already said these steps are labor
intensive and prone to error and
variability and require years of
multiple types of equipment so Milton e
biotech has developed an instrument
which offers an automated cell
processing solution called clean Emacs
prodigy and this instrument performs
integrated cell processing from starting
material to final killer product
improving sample preparation cell
washing density gradient separation
max cell separation cell activation
genetic modification cell culture and
final product formulation and therefore
it enables a complex process to be fully
automated and controlled and it it's
done in the close to single-use tubing
cell system so the manufacturing and
distribution of autologous xvo solar
products is complex and it's hard to
scale if early development stages such
as I envy and phase 1 clinical trials
may require only small amount of
patients to be enrolled as the studies
proceed to phase 2 and phase 3 and
finally commercialization much larger
amount of patients are enrolled and much
larger scale is required for the product
manufacturing and it has been already
noted that the challenge of scale is a
bottleneck in Carty therapies today so
there are few of different models for
manufacturing car T cells one is the
centralized model and another is point
of care model in the in the centralized
model the patient is being treated at a
hospital and his blood is being
collected at the hospital and then is
transported to a centralized location
where cell processing occurs and then
it's being transported back into the
hospital where the patient is in
administered that's one model in the
point-of-care model of the facility
where the cells are being produced is
found in the proximity to the hospital
and this allows more streamlined and
less logistically laborious processing
of cells so today for example the
manufacturing of CTL 17 CTL 19 product
sorry is a strong demonstration of
centralized processing the patient is
referred to the trial the cells are
obtained and then the cells are
transferred usually flown in to a
centralized processing facility in
Morris Plains New Jersey and processed
and then flown back and then delivered
in the hospital and and the patient
receives therapy and then the other
option alternative to that is point of
care model where everything would be
done at the same location pretty much
and there are less processing steps less
handlink
so now I would like to say a few words
about carting clinical trials and by
just giving you an example of a process
through which cells are prepared for a
trial so in a typical trials the
lymphocytes would be collected from the
patient about 11 days prior to karti
administration and year they that time T
cells would be activated expanded
transfused to the car and then expanded
formulated and finally given to the
patient and usually a prior to party
administration chemotherapy is given
which usually consists of food urban and
cyclophosphamide so the application of
chemotherapy is important because lymph
depletion is very important for a
maximal Carty function and that is for a
number of reasons the names of depletion
make space for car T cells to engraft
through several mechanisms one is by
increasing the level of free cytokines
il-7 and I'll 15 and the body that are
available to stimulate car T cells and
other mechanism is by removing
regulatory t-cells which might be
inhibitory to karti function and finally
by altering tumour and bone marrow
environment which again potentiates the
functionality of car t-cells
so some of the ongoing clinical trials
the most prominent one probably is the
Novartis CTL year one nine trial alienum
it's a trial for pediatric and young
adults with relapsed or refractory
b-cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia and
it's the basis of DLA and so far 82
percent of complete responses have been
reported this is a very good result and
the pivotal beta is supported by CTL
zero and nine multicenter trial called
ensign as well as earlier single side
trial so this trial showed relapse free
survival rate at six months of sixty
percent it enrolled in twenty five
centers across Europe the United States
Canada Australia and Japan of about
forty eight percent of patients had
great fear for cytokine release syndrome
but but they were no death in this trial
and 15 percent of patients had greatly
neurological and psychiatric events
including encephalopathy in delirium
that's one of the side effects that is
known to be associated with car
treatment and the overall response in
the adults was 47% in diffuse large
b-cell lymphoma three months and it was
73% percent in follicular lymphoma
another child for product k TC 19 has
been conducted by kite actually it's a
series of trials called Zuma and again
here they are both some of our phase 1
and phase 2 again it showed very good
over overall responses at 3 months and
for some endpoints the data at six and
nine months was released and it's
also pretty good so here is just an
illustration of a patient that has been
treated in Zuma trial and as you can see
there is a response to treatment so jr.
is another company that is actively
conducting Carty trials there are
several trials ongoing je car
0:14 is a lien conducted at fed Fred
Hutchinson Cancer Center and it's a car
19 with TG of our tech generated by
lentiviral transduction another child
Jake r15 was unfortunately terminated
and another ongoing trial is jake r17
conducted at Seattle Children's Hospital
the construct also has a TG of our tags
and in this trial a defined combination
of cd4 and cd8 cells one to one
combination is used and the cells are
transfuse Valenti viral vectors and in
this trial the results are also very
promising so cyclophosphamide only
conditioning produced eight percent
complete responses and 50 percent
overall response cyclophosphamide with
flowed Aravind
conditioning produced 50 percent CR CR s
and 72 percent overall response rate and
at maximum tolerated dose the
combination chemotherapy produced 82
percent overall response rate so now I
want to say a few words about and K
cells so in case are another type of
immune cells which are capable of
killing tumors and the possibility of
using in case in in SS car cells is
being investigated this is a relatively
new emerging area of study but there are
several ongoing clinical trials at this
time
one is 1/3 by MD Anderson Cancer Center
and another by Baylor College of
Medicine and there is a couple of trials
in China so this is a promising new area
so to summarize Carty cells continue to
show great potential in the treatment of
cancer further improvements to the
efficacy and safety of car therapy are
being developed the use of antiviral
vectors and automated integrated
clinical manufacturing protocols offers
solutions for streamlined car production
and multiple clinical trials are on the
way for underway for car seat products
it's actually the counter than the
hundreds and there are several car and
key trials ongoing as well and Karan
keys are emerging as a new approach in
car based therapies so with that I will
conclude and I will be happy to take
your questions
well thank you dr. Schneider for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. Schneider please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started
first question is you mentioned in your
presentation that key cells were
selected using anti cd4 and anti cd8
beads are there any other reagents
available for the selection of t-cells
yes in fact cd6 t2l reagent is available
as well
forces of selective cv6 t2l positive
cells and use of that reagent may in
fact result in a product that has a
higher component of central memory
t-cells which as I have shown you are
predicted to be more functional in vivo
what are the side effects associated
with Karki treatment yes so currently
there are a few major side effects which
have been described in multiple trials
one is cytokine release syndrome and
this
side effect is basically typical of a
class of drugs it's typical of
monoclonal antibodies and also seen with
car t-cells and it's usually manifests
as fever nausea chills hypertension and
this Nia and in severe form it might
even be fatal but the good news is that
there is a drug that can be used to
minimize cytokine relief syndrome it's
an il-6
receptor antagonist called socialism amp
and it has been able to manage cytokine
release syndrome in many patients
another type of toxicity is a neurologic
toxicity and it's being investigated
currently and what is known to date is
that both the CRF cytokine release
syndrome and neither lost neurologic
toxicity occur more when either high
tumor burden is present or where hide
those of car t-cells is being given or
the patient's had prior history of
central nervous system problems and so
all of these observations will help in
the future to determine which patients
are more at risk and to give appropriate
doses of skirty cells to prevent similar
diseases from occurring
is it possible to culture T cells on
clinics prodigy with other cytokines
rather than il-2 yes indeed one option
that comes to mind is the use of aisle 7
and aisle 15 and this may result in you
know even Peter better cartoon shells
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Schneider for her presentation
do you have any final comments
yes I would like to thank lipids the
organizers for giving us the chance to
present and I would like to thank all my
colleagues at olanta gen technology and
all my colleagues at Milton you by
attack for being part of this wonderful
work and I feel very fortunate to be a
part of that well thank you once again I
would also like to thank our sponsor
Milton E biotech for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye